MALE SPEAKER: Since
Android 2.0, you've
been able to take
advantage of instant run
to dramatically increase
your incremental builds.
But did you know
that Android 2.1
enables Dex in Process
to improve the time taken
for full builds, as well
as improving instant run
performance?
Dex in Process allows
multiple Dex processes
to run within a single VM
that's also shared with Gradle,
a feature that significantly
improves build times,
including initial
and clean builds.
That means you need to
increase the maximum heap
size of the Gradle daemon
to incorporate the memory
requirements of
the Dex processes.
Open your project's
gradle.properties,
and modify it from the
default value of one gig
to at least two.
We're incorporating the
memory requirements of Dex.
So if you've increased
the Java max heap
size in your module
level build.gradle file
from default of one
gig, you'll need
to increase the Gradle
daemon's VM size accordingly.
The best values vary, so
experiment with the max heap
size and Gradle daemon
VM values to see
what values work best for you.
Upgrade to Android
Studio 2.1 now,
and increase the memory
allocation of your Gradle
daemon VM to at least two
gigs, to enable Dex in Process
and enjoy much faster
build times for all
your Android projects.